we are just getting into labor day
weekend i know it's hard to believe
aren't you thinking did we have a summer
for many americans
this is the last opportunity for a
summer getaway
despite the pandemic people want to go
millions are expected to go
somewhere but because of the coronavirus
air travel is down way down about 70
percent compared to this time last year
people who are flying though are
starting to see new touchless technology
rolling out all across the country chris
van cleeve looks at some of the systems
launching this week
before her flight from chicago to fort
myers abby weber is checking a bag
in a new way one spirit hopes is a game
changer that speeds up the process by 30
percent
while reducing touch points and
encouraging distance during the pandemic
i think it's cool i think it helps not
having to talk to an agent
it works by using technology instead of
people to verify a traveler's identity
when checking bags there we go i think
it could expedite
checking bags and getting to your gayden
time the first in the nation kiosks are
now operating at o'hare and new york's
laguardia airport
they validate your id and use biometrics
to compare that picture with one taken
on the spot
at o'hare alone the optional system
could eliminate 600 daily interactions
between flyers and employees
what happens to those pictures after i
am finished it will go through the
recognition here
it will do the validation in the match
here and then it will
evaporate spirit ceo
ted christie you know before coronavirus
you would not necessarily want to
discourage your employees from
interacting with
your customers but that's all changed
comfort
is important to people and that changes
as a result of the coronavirus and so
less interaction can be valued more by
certain
members of our guest seventy-nine
percent of business flyers and nearly
three-quarters of leisure travelers say
it's important airlines and airports
maximize the use of touchless
contactless technology
travel analyst henry hartevelt if they
can check out of a store or supermarket
using touchless technology they want
that at the airport and on the airplane
at washington's reagan national the tsa
began testing similar technology at a
checkpoint this week
the passenger puts their id in the
scanner that photo is compared to one
taken by this camera
the tsa officer monitoring the process
stays behind plexiglas
and lax is the first in the u.s to try
check-in kiosks where you can use your
smartphone
as a mouse so you never have to touch
the screen
passengers at the la airport's
international terminal can use the 12
kiosks to check
in for flights on nearly two dozen
airlines for cbs this morning chris van
vancleave
chicago kudos to the airlines trying to
keep us safe we thank you for that